i first heard about ramona boss when he
was arrested
it was a pretty big international news
story he was arrested in dubai
and he was very quickly extradited to
the
u.s ramona boss also known as hush puppy
was responsible for a number of business
email compromise scams
but what he was most known for was being
an instagram influencer he built a
following of millions of people and it
was always very mysterious where his
money actually came from
according to the affidavit he was
charged with 30 million dollars worth of
fraud
us poppy
is the number one yahoo boy in nigeria
is a role model to every yahoo boy in
nigeria
there are ways to look at hush puppy not
as some kind of hero but you can respect
some of the things that he did and the
way that he thrived in our current
online social media ecosystem
one of the things people would ask me
was why did he post instagram like he
should have just kept a low profile my
answer ultimately was why do you post on
social media i mean he was doing it for
the same reasons we all do it to get
some response from people to feel his
place in the world grow and be respected
when you look at the story
from one layer it's very simplistic but
the deeper you get into it the more you
see the complexities around how someone
like hush puppy exists in the modern
world
[Music]
ramon grew up in a neighborhood of lagos
called oron shoki it's a bit of a hard
scrabble neighborhood his father drove a
taxi his mother sold bread and other
foods on the street by his own account
he always looked to sort of the ritzier
areas of lagos as a kind of dreamer and
he he wanted to have more for himself
today we have an exclusive inside look
at the internet scan that has been
sweeping this country based out of
nigeria
when the internet arrived late 90s early
2000s in places like ramona boss's
neighborhood people would go down to the
internet cafe and one of the things that
nigerians discovered when they logged on
was that oftentimes there was sort of a
reputation that preceded them online
they were already viewed as being
scammers because of the 419 scams of the
80s and 90s which were basically either
phone or fax or letter scams this
coincided as well with more difficult
economic times within nigeria fewer job
prospects and so there was a community
who sort of embraced that label who
decided okay i will figure out how to
make money online i will figure out how
to take advantage of people
and they're actually incredibly
innovative it started as it almost
always does with an email there was a
community of young boys who became known
as yahoo boys based on the free email
accounts that were available for this
type of scamming
i spoke to a criminologist in nigeria
adeji who he spent a lot of time with
yahoo boys and he actually
lived for a time among them to study
them to understand their motivations to
understand their techniques to see what
became of them over time and he knew a
lot of the same people in ramon's circle
i had a very good relationship with them
because i saw them as human beings
it was
very popular in islams
areas like barriga agung lay egora
motion because these are places where
you have a lot of young boys who have
very little life chances
us poppy ramon abbas at that time it was
one of the very smart boys
he went very far he met a lot of people
who could help him
improve on the skills of cyber crime
knowing that
the kind of cyber crime we had in
nigeria in the early days was close to
the 419 the later scan
he moved from nigeria to malaysia and at
the time in particular there was a sort
of exodus of yahoo boys from nigeria to
malaysia
there are a variety of theories about
why they moved there the possibility
that it was a little more lax that the
nigerian government was paying a little
more attention at that time also because
there was more sophisticated internet
architecture there
in terms of how you could hide the
location that your requests were coming
from
he moved closer to where he could have
access to all of the tools he wanted
more information than
what every other person had and that was
why it became
what most of them did not become
it seems like he was connected to
several different flavors of scams one
of which was
business emo compromise which is the
most lucrative internet scam that exists
well today one of the largest scams
attacking end users is called the
business email compromise the business
email compromise seems really really
sophisticated and during my career i've
dealt with hundreds of these incidents
the bad guys are able to compromise an
email account of a business could be a
small business could be a large business
and it involves financial transactions
you have a company and
the company is going to be targeted by
the scammers and usually they'll
research the company they're trying to
find the right person and what they do
is a hacker gets access to someone's
email account so usually middle manager
or someone in the accounting department
of a company
once they're in the email they don't
actually do anything they just sit there
and they wait and they watch the flow of
email in and out and when they see
invoices that's what they're looking for
when an invoice comes in they might
spoof the email of the sender of the
invoice mock up a fake invoice that
looks exactly like the one that just
came in and then send a follow-up email
saying this was not the correct bank
account information this is the new bank
so
if the
financial department is not looking
carefully then they are prone to
sending the money right out the door
that's essentially what bec scams are
someone asked for this money who's not
the right person and you sent them
millions of dollars
[Music]
ramon
had picked up the handle hush puppy in i
think 2012 but it was really when he got
to malaysia that he started posting
photos
mostly of himself
it was a kid from lagos on the rise
here are the luxury brands that i'm now
consuming and he sort of started mixing
that with a kind of
self-help
mantras and a sort of prosperity gospel
you know the hustle
his followers started sort of ticking up
over time
and then hush puppy began a friendship
with mumfa who's a very very well-known
influencer in nigeria and mumfo lived in
dubai
that seems like the time when he started
to see that there was another level of
opulence there was another tier of
lifestyle that he could be living and so
he packed up from malaysia moved himself
to dubai
when he moved to dubai he really entered
this world of
truly high wealth individuals which
included obtaining a penthouse apartment
closets full of designer clothes
shelves of unopened sneakers sneakers
that had only been made one sneakers
that had been made
specifically for him and a basement
parking garage that was full of cars
like ferraris bentleys he's sometimes
now flying on private planes he's one of
the guests of honor at the formula one
race he's being invited to big events in
dubai and so he's kind of entered this
upper crust of
some of the most wealthy people in the
world everything you want [ __ ] around
the difference between us poppy and the
other yahoo boys is the fact that it
went international
then we went to the social media to
show off all of these things
but as for recklessness they are all
reckless even those who are not on the
international scenes
are also reckless that's the way they
live
so hush puppy's 37th birthday it was all
kind of at that moment it felt like it
was really coming together for a hush
puppy and he posted about that he posted
about how far he had come
while that birthday celebration was
happening
the sort of seeds of of hush puppy's
downfall had already kind of been sown
well he made the cardinal sin in
organized crime he flaunted his wealth
he brought a lot of attention to himself
he made himself appear to be a national
hero but when you were out there and you
were flaunting all of this information
there's so much open source intelligence
that he was just providing about himself
the fbi arrested a canadian money
launderer and his name was galab
al-amari
when they arrested al-mari he
had a phone on him
in which there were contacts for hush
puppy and there were message exchanges
with hush puppy
what they came to believe was that
alimari and hush puppy were sort of part
of a loosely networked group of people
who were committing bec scams
and moving the money around the world
oftentimes there would be hackers who
would hack into the email accounts and
the fbi later concluded these were north
korean state-sponsored hackers who had
actually committed billions of dollars
worth of crime around the world over the
past 10 years al-amari would connect up
with hush puppy ask him if he had any
bank accounts and when a big be score
was about to happen hushpug would
provide a bank account that could
receive millions of dollars that were
about to be transferred out of a company
the crimes that they were accused of
included the large-scale hacking of a
bank in malta for 13 million dollars a
bec scam on an american law firm for
just under a million dollars the biggest
one was an attempted bec scam on two uk
companies both of which were for around
100 million dollars and one of which was
an english premier league football team
in early june june 8th hush puppy was
asleep upstairs on the second floor of
his apartment
there was a bang on the door and then
suddenly the apartment was full of
people with guns at first he thought
they were victims of an armed robbery
but then it quickly turned out with the
dubai swat team and they had come in
fully kitted up they were ready for war
he was
whisked onto a plane within i think 24
to 48 hours and sent to the u.s if you
are to classify philosophy how would you
classify
boston
i give a lot of credit to the fbi agents
who arrested hush puppies but we are not
going to arrest our way out of this
problem we took one bad guy off the
streets but how many more of them are
out there
i think even though we believe mr abbas
is a major player in this
he's only a bit player in the entire
infrastructure of the complete
organization
there are just so many actors and so
many elements in these schemes including
organized crime in places like russia in
places like brazil that
it's really really hard to make a dent i
think in the power of the bec scam
to me one of the tragedies of
this whole situation
is that because of the reputation of
scamming in nigeria law enforcement
there particularly with the special
anti-robbery squad they ended up using
scammers and yahoo boys as just a
pretext
all of a sudden down the street
arresting every young guy for being
involved in cyber crime without any
evidence
they just packed a group of young boys
they forced them to see a lot of things
and then poon
it became one of the reasons why we had
what we had in nigeria last year
for weeks now there have been
demonstrations against police brutality
across africa's most populous country
protesters accuse the now disbanded
special anti-robbery squad or sars of
torture they've been notorious for
extrajudicial killings
and
harassment especially of young nigerians
and southern nigeria was a big deal last
year
a lot of lives were lost and up to this
moment we are still trying to pacify
young people
cyber crime is not a problem
of nigeria or for nigeria
is a problem from every part of the
world
we need a global cyber crime law if we
have a law and we also have global law
enforcement agencies then we are moving
towards managing cyber crime
you